one thing that Twitter recently did was
update the video product and it's
incredible and so what I do is I look at
my screen now people want content and
that's what all these platforms are
great for but what they really want is
access and effort so access is actually
like live streaming and all that stuff
and that's why periscope meerkat you
know all the other platforms future
video products cuz live video is gonna
map just like it did on TV it's gonna
matter but what they also want is effort
so I can reply and say thanks and people
get super excited about that and you get
excited when somebody you care about
whether Instagram celebrity Twitter
celebrity or real-life celebrity comes
and and does that because you that they
took an extra second it takes three
seconds instead of one second is a video
reply which is why when I video reply I
get such a bigger reaction because
people understand that every second is
so valuable time is the asset so if
you're giving your time to me you care
and that's why this matters so Nick
blamin who's a great business associate
he's the president of digital at NBC
Universal he's sue on a super health
kick and in the health space so he I put
out a health content yesterday he said
words of fitness by Gary and wisdom by
Gary Vee Thank You Nick
so now I could say cool or I can watch
this it doesn't take long Nick I hit my
video button I hit my video button I
reverse my camera I hit the camera four
clicks I wanted to do the same Hobie
every day brother boom those nights
seconds matter those nine seconds done
and reply done next cashes oxygen via
gary v pam likes that quote I like that
quote I use it a lot pam has been
following and we've been engaging on
twitter for a long time but I've never
made the video well good to see you soon
at some conference maybe you fix
yourself I cool boom again nine seconds
I'm on this nine second kick nine
seconds of effort instead of three what
does that do my intuition is it makes
pam it makes Nick realize they matter to
me I know who they are I care about them
enough well here's a big one this is
good timing Daymond John Shark Tank the
man looking for a new reader here are my
five favorite books
thank you gotta go [ __ ] I'm at that's
it time is the asset give time to your
fans your followers the people that care
care a little bit more than the next guy
than the next girl and see the returns
people want to say that it's not about
the hard work they want to say it's
about working smart it's just not it's
about both use the tools that are in
place today show a little extra effort
go deep and set up wide don't worry
about how many followers you have and
how you can spam them all try to make
connections deeper one by one they will
last longer they will mean more there's
more leverage in them use Twitter video
the right way and and see the results
I appreciate you DJ for that lets you
pass it on jab jab jab right hook also
do me a favor
you have Ted hit me up yes I'm talking
about
you